[Music]
good evening and welcome to money fame
and value i'm your host miriam frassler
thank you for joining us today's
successful artists from damien hurst to
jeff coons often portray themselves as
rejecting the norms of society and
present their work as a challenge to the
establishment
yet in practice they couldn't be more
part of the status quo the five most
celebrated artists have a combined worth
of two billion dollars
are today's galleries monuments to money
fame and status rather than monuments to
artistic merits
is it a fallacy to imagine an artist can
be hugely commercially successful and
counter-cultural at the same time
or is it prejudiced to suppose that the
rich
can't also be critics of the system that
has propelled their success
well to help me unpack these questions
and many more i have a wonderful panel
joining me this evening kicking off with
georgina adam who is a journalist art
market expert and author who has written
for the financial times and the arts
newspaper she's the author of big bucks
and dark side of the boom the excesses
of the art market in the 21st century
next we have jan teller who is a
celebrated novelist and essayist having
previously worked in macroeconomics
despite being initially banned her novel
nothing has won numerous awards in
various languages teller's work is often
aimed at young adults and belongs to the
existentialist tradition and last but
certainly not least paddy johnson is the
editor of the forthcoming book
impractical spaces and the founding
editor of the contemporary art blog
art f city she's a two-time nominee for
best critic at the rob pruitt awards and
also contributes to vice observer and
cnn very warm welcome to our wonderful
panel thank you for being with us
tonight um we're going to kick off by
giving each of you three minutes to
respond to this first question
is art now more about money fame and
status than artistic
merit
uh georgina do you want to kick us off
on that one i guess that is a very
annoying answer i'm going to come up
with i think you have to start by
defining artistic merit and i think you
have to start by saying
who is the person who judges what
artistic merit is
so even before we get on to these
aspects i think you have to look at who
is it who's actually
setting the critical agenda today um it
used to be our critics
uh
there's a big temptation to say now that
it's perhaps gallerists like gagosian
you know who spread their
tentacles across the world with
galleries and can show artists
right across the world and compromi
promote them in ways that was probably
not possible before
so i guess that um
my question really and i think we should
be discussing is is
how today do we judge artistic merit and
once
if we can possibly work that one out
then we can see whether money
fame and status
correspond to that so that would be my
rather annoying first comment opening
gambit thank you georgina uh janna
is art now more about money fame and
status than artistic merit your three
minutes starts now when we talk about
the art market and the art scene
my answer would be yes absolutely money
is money and fame and status is
unfortunately determining where the
attention goes
but if we then look at from the artist's
point of view
then money famous status does not
necessarily play in at all it really
depends on the individual artist
what you choose if you simply just need
to express something then you you don't
go for the status of money and there are
other types of artists where you know
the status or the money comes absolutely
first
and unfortunately then they also get the
attention because that's the world we
live in right now
at least in the short term not
necessarily in the longer term
but
you know on the
third level what i also want to do is
distinguish between art forms because
um
speculation the kind of money
speculation we see when it is you know
the big millions involved it only works
or influences
art that
depends on the singularity of the piece
uh forms like literature or music or
films that can be reproduced as many
times as you want without influencing
the actual art
money doesn't play in the same way it
can still play in in terms of some
riders choosing to write thrillers just
to sell a lot more because they are the
monies but it's nothing even for those
who sell a lot it's nothing compared to
you know the speculation that goes into
the unique art piece
and just before i finish i want to come
back to my first yes about the art
market and the art scene
because i think there's something you
know
that we we also have to take in in the
further discussion and i'll use two very
different examples in the early part of
this century and the art experts will
probably know much more about this than
i do this gallery
i hope i pronounced it correctly nerdler
had this human scandal
of selling i mean
i think with something like 40 pieces of
very expensive art um that were fixed
over a long period of time
and and we're talking about you know
jackson pollock's um
and uh
these pieces people bought and they were
happy about having paid millions for
them
until the moment they figure out that
it's a fake
so therefore it comes back to in a way
what um georgina was saying the merit if
somebody
looks at a piece they think is a rotco
or a jackson pollock and therefore thing
is valued of more than 20 million
dollars
but the moment they don't
you know they realize it's not this
artist's work
then it has no value at all and i you
know i think we shall come back to it
later because here i can only mention it
and the last thing i want to introduce
us is this new art form of the
non-fungible tokens and i hope can you
see it if i hold this one up this piece
has been sold a few months ago i mean
not as a paper version but in the
virtual space for 69 million dollars um
the artist calls himself people it's
mike winkleman
and the only thing that makes this so
valuable it's it's 5 000 different posts
he's done online since 2007 that he's
put together in one but is that the
person who buys it gets like an
authenticated line that says he
owns
this one singular piece but as i
understand it's because of it being the
internet a lot of people can actually
copy it and and then
it will exist for others but he will
have the authorized version that you
know is the 69 million worth so i think
we live in a money world that is is
almost like an illusion except
it's there it's for real in a strange
way and influences are so yeah this was
my
attempt to have
separated into some different levels
thank you so much and patty over to you
you know i think georgina really got at
the heart of it when she talked about um
value and what how value is arrived at
and i think what we're talking about
often when we talk about value um and
cultural value is how much attention
something gets right and how we get
attention to that particular thing
because ultimately i think if we look at
what art the function of art just sort
of generally in like the most kind of
pie in the sky version of what we think
art is it's an expression and reflection
of cultural values but it's also what we
want the world to be so placing a value
on that um is
through an attention economy is also
like reflecting our own values
now how those values used to come used
to be determined was through a small
handful of white men right we had
clement greenberg um we had michael
freeman we had these white critics and
they yielded a lot awful lot of power
and what we ended up with was a cannon
that was very white and filled with
white men right so we knew that was that
was the
a flawed way of going about it so what
is different with the world that we have
now in instagram
um and twitter and like this diverse
audience
well
it's still controlled by a handful of
white tech dudes
right these are the people that control
the algorithms these are the people
that
um have a lot of say
over the attention economy that we have
and they also um tend to be the primary
bidders on things like nfts which um you
know just came up
so
i think there are a lot of ways that we
can um evaluate art but i think
a lot of them come down to like
what
um
what gets attention and what doesn't and
the reason that that is so imbalanced
is because if you have money
you have
um a way of giving something attention
that it may or may not deserve
right and so this imbalance creates tons
of problems and inequity globally
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you